สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 2  23 ค่ะค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
คะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวัน
ที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 1800 น 1800 น 1800 น 18:00 นค่ะอ่า
1800 นกี่
นาที 1800 น 5 นาทีค่ะ 65 นก็เป็นตอนเช้า
ก็เป็นเวลากลางวันอืเวลากลางวันวันนี้
เนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าตื่นเช้ามากนะคะ
ทำไมครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าถึงตื่นเช้าจังเลย
ค่ะใช่เพราะว่าเรา 2 คนเนี่ยคิดค่ะครู
ฟ้าคิดคิดิดอันนี้ครูฟ้านะคะ
คิดไงเราเนี่ย
คิดคิดอะไรอ่ะผู้หญิงเ้าคิดจะไปเที่ยวไง
คะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันศุกร์แล้วเดี๋ยวก็วัน
เสาร์แล้วก็วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยวันเสาร์วัน
อาทิตย์เรา 2 คนเนี่ยไม่ต้องสอนภาษาไทย
แล้วก็ไปเที่ยว
ไงอยู่บ้านทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันเ่ะเออ
เบื่อค่ะอืไปเที่ยวหรอคะอืมค่ะไปเที่ยว
ที่ไหนดีพัทยา
มั้ยก็ได้นะเพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยอยู่
กรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็ไปพัทยาก็ไป
เที่ยวค่ะอ้าอือ้าแต่ครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยาโอเค
ครูฟ้ามาเที่ยว
กรุงเทพฯครูฟ้าอยู่
อะไรนะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยอยู่กรุงเทพฯอันนี้
หญิงใช่มั้ยก็ไปพัทยาฟ้าพัทยาก็มา
กรุงเทพฯโอเคมยเราไม่ต้องเจอกันครูฟ้ากับ
ครูหญิงก็ไปเที่ยวคนเดียวเหรอทำไมไม่ได้
สิครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องมากรุงเทพฯครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ไปพัทยาเรา 2 คนเนี่ยมาเจอกันที่
กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปเที่ยว
ประเทศไทยอ๋อเราจะไปเที่ยวประเทศ
ไทยใช่ค่ะโอกรุงเทพฯก็คือดาวเนี่ยนะคะนัก
เรียนนี่กรุงเทพฯอือ่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเค้า
อยู่ที่นี่มั้ยพัทยาประมาณนี้มั้ยอืๆอื
ครูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้าก็สีฟ้าแล้วกันเพราะว่าเ
ตัวเชื่อฟ้านะคะนี่ครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยาครู
หญิงเนี่ยอยู่กรุงเทพฯครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องมา
มากรุงเทพฯ
อืก็ได้ค่ะครูฟ้าจะเดินโอ๊ยครูฟ้ามา
กรุงเทพฯเดินกี่
วัน
เดินฟ้าน่าจะเดินประมาณ 3 ปีนะคะนัก
เรียนเพราะว่าเดินไปด้วยกินไปด้วยเดินไป
ด้วยกินไปด้วยไม่ถึงกรุงเทพฯสักทีเดินไม่
ได้
แล้วจาก
พัทยาเนี่ยพัทยาเ้าสละตัวเอหายนะคะพัทยา
มากรุงเทพฯ
เนี่ยนั่งรถไฟได้
ไหมไม่ได้
มเออน่าจะไม่ได้มันใช่แต่มันมีรถไฟนะมีรถ
ไฟจาก
กรุงเทพฯจากกรุงเทพนะคะแล้วก็ไปพัทยา
เนี่ย
มีนะหรอครูฟ้าไม่รู้เลยนะคะไม่เคยฟ้าไม่
เคยงั้นก็ไม่นั่งรถไฟใช่มยไม่ค่ะรถทัวร์
นั่งรถทัวร์อันนี้โอเคค่ะทุกวันนะคะูฟ้า
นั่งรถทัวร์มา
กรุงเทพฯเลยเหรอคะูฟ้านั่งรถทัวร์นะคะรู
ฟ้าแล้วรถทัวร์จากพัทยา pty เนี่ยนะคะพ
พัทยามา
กรุงเทพฯกี่
[เพลง]
ชั่วโมงประมาณ 2
ชมงกี่
บาท
บาทโอเคมั้ยคะเย็นแอร์โอเคมั้ยรถทัวร์มี
แอร์ใช่ไมยมีค่ะแอร์เย็นนะคะนักเรียน
เย็นครูฟ้าหลับสบายเลยใช่ค่ะ
อ่า
เย็นค่ะถ้าอย่างงั้นเวลาครูฟ้าจะมา
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็นั่งรถทัวร์เนาะ
เพราะว่าน่าจะเร็วกว่าใช่ค่ะครูฟ้านั่งรถ
ทัวร์ตลอดใช่ถ้าูฟ้านั่งรถไฟเนี่ยก็ไม่
รู้ขึ้นที่ไหนก็อาจจะซัก
4 ชั่วโมงมั้ยอืรถไฟอืนานมากใช่อืพอครู
ฟ้ามากรุงเทพฯแล้วเรามาอยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้ว
เนี่ยประเทศไทยเนี่ยนะคะก็จะมีภาคเหนือ
ใช่ไหอันนี้เอาสีนี้ดีกว่านี่ใช่มยคะภาค
เหนือเชียงใหม่เชียงรายภาคเหนือใช่มั้ยคะ
อันนี้ภาคกลางเนาะจริงๆกรุงเทพฯก็อยู่ภาค
กลางนี่แหละภาคกลางก็อยุธยาสุโขทัยนะถ้า
นักเรียนจะรู้จักนะคะอืแล้วก็ภาคอีสานนะ
นะฮะภาคอีสานก็ขอนแก่นอุดรอืหนองคายออัน
นี้ภาคตะวันตกนะคะภาคตะวันตกก็ติดกับ
เมียนมาร์อันนี้คือเมียนมาร์นะคะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้เขียนยังไงอ่ะ
เมียนมาร์อืแล้วก็ภาคใต้ใช่มั้ยภูเก็ต
กระบี่นี่คือภูเก็ตใช่มั้ยคะภาคใต้ครูฟ้า
อยากจะไปเที่ยวภาคไหนก่อนอืม
ครูฝานะคะคิดว่าเที่ยวอันนี้ได้มั้ยเออ
ลืมขอบคุณค่ะลืมบ้านตัวเองนะคะภาคตะวัน
ออกพัทยาระยองเกาะช้างนี่ลืมภาคตัวเองนะ
คะนี่ไงะครูพ้าอยาก
เี้ยวคิดนานจังคิดก่อนเที่ยวตะวันออกเหรอ
ก็ได้เ้าตะวันออกมันไม่ได้มีแค่พัทยาไง
มันก็มีใช่ระยองจันทบุรีอันนี่เกาะช้าง
ใช่มั้ยจังหวัดตราชเนี่ยเกาะช้างนะคะก็
ถ้าเราจะไปเที่ยวภาคตะวัน
ออกเราก็ต้องเดินทางใช่ไหมมเราจะครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะเดินไปก็ไม่ได้ขับรถ
ก็เรา 2 คนเนี่ยไม่มีรถรถขับรถก็ไม่เป็น
ก็คือครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะ
คะอยู่บ้านที่ตะวันออกแล้วครูฟ้าก็นั่งรถ
ไปหาครูหญิงที่กรุงเทพฯเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้า
กับครูหญิงก็มาที่ตะวัน
ออกนักเรียนก็น่าจะรู้แล้วว่าคุณฟ้าไอค
ประมาณไหน IQ  EQ โอเคไยนะคะอุ้ยวัดผิด
เลยนะคะอ่ะถ้านักเรียนแต่ถ้านักเรียน
เนี่ยอยากจะไปภาคตะวันออกใช่มั้ยครูหญิง
จะซูมแล้วซูมกลับได้มก็ไม่รู้นะคะนัก
เรียนนี่อ่านี่คือภาคตะวันออกนะคะรูปก็
ไม่ชัดนะอไม่ชัดเลยค่ะใช่ค่ะก็เอากลับดี
กว่าเนาะ
อืก็ไม่ต้องรู้หรอกนะคะว่ามันมีจังหวัด
อะไรบ้างไม่เป็นไรนะคะอนมันไม่ชัดนะคะแต่
ถ้านักเรียนอยากจะไปภาคตะวันออกเนี่ยนะคะ
จากกรุงเทพฯนี่นะนี่จากกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยรถไฟ
เนี่ยไม่โอเคไม่ต้องเลือกนั่งรถไฟไปนะคะ
นักเรียนอือมันไปได้แค่ถึงชลบุรีเท่านั้น
ก็คือเลยพัทยานิดหน่อยนะคะอือรถทัวดีที่
สุด The  Best  The  Best ใช่ค่ะอยากจะ
พูดคำว่า The  Best เหมือนกันรถทัวร์ค่ะ
นักเรียนถ้านักเรียนอยู่กรุงเทพฯนะคะนัก
เรียนก็นั่งไปที่
BTS สถานีอะไรคะเอกมัยป่ะเอกมัยอือ่านะ
BTS นะคะสถานีเอกมัย
Exit อะไรไม่รู้ถามสตาฟ BTS นะคะแล้วก็
บอกว่ามันจะมีอท่ารถใช่มยท่ารถเนาะก็จะมี
รถทัวร์เยอะมากๆนะคะที่ไปภาคตะวันออกเนาะ
ไป
ชลบุรีไป
ระยองอืไปจันทบุรีไปเกาะช้างนะคะครูหญิง
เขียนภาษาอังกฤษนะคะนักเรียนเกาะชเกาะ
ช้างอ่าเกาะกูดนะคะไปภาคตะวันออกเนี่ยมี
รถทัวร์ทั้งหมดเลยนะคะ BTS สถานีเอกมัยรถ
ทัวร์เพราะว่ารถทัวร์เนี่ยคิดว่าถ้าจาก
คือชลบุรีก็จะใกล้สุด
เนาะไกลที่สุดก็คือเกาะช้างเนี่ยนะคะเกาะ
ช้างเนี่ยคุณหญิงก็คิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ 2
ถึง 6  2-6 ชมงได้มั้ยถึงจังหวัดกราด
เนี่ยถึงที่เนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนถึงที่นี่น
จังหวัดตราไม่แน่ใจนะอาจจะ 2 ถึง 5
ช่วโมงแล้วกันครุหญิงไม่คิดว่ามันจะนาน
ขนาดนั้นนะคะน่าจะประมาณ 2-5 ชมง
อืรถทัวร์ได้นะคะแล้วก็รถตู้ได้อืรถตู้
อันนี้โอเค
มย
อืมถ้าไม่มีช้อยส์ถ้าถ้ามีช้อยส์นะคะนัก
เรียนระหว่างรถตู้กับรถทัวร์ครูหญิงก็ยัง
แนะนำรถทัวร์นะคะเพราะว่าขับอดีใช่มยคน
ขับเนี่ยขับดีนะคะรถตู้แบบนี้ไม่ค่อยโอเค
แต่ถ้ารถตู้แบบนี้โอเคนะอันนี้โอเคหรอใช่
ดูมันยาวกว่าไงคนขับดีกว่าเออก็อาจจะเป็น
ช้อยส์ที่ 2 ใช่มยถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยดูเวลา
แล้วรถทัวร์ไม่โอเคก็รดตู้อันนี้แล้วก็
อันนี้้อยนะคะอย่าเลือกมันเร็วมากอืใช่
ค่ะน้องเรียนรถทัวร์นะคะภาคตะวันออกเนาะ
อืก็
โอเคเที่ยวภาคตะวันออกเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้า
อยากจะไปเที่ยวภาคไหนอีกคะภาคตะวันออกไม่
เอาแล้วนะเพราะว่าเที่ยวไปแล้วครูฟ้าอยาก
ไป
เที่ยวอีสานออครูฟ้าอยากจะไปอีสานอนะคะไป
อีสานเนี่ยรถไฟได้โอเคหรอคะรถไฟเนี่ยโอเค
ค่ะส่วนใหญ่รถไฟเนี่ยก็จะออกตอนกลางคืน
ใช่มั้ยกลางคืนเนี่ยจากอกรุงเทพฯนะคะแล้ว
ก็จะไปถึง
อีสานตอนเช้าอ่าสมมุติว่า 5 อ่า 18:00 น
อ่ะ 18:00
นเย็นเนาะ 18:00 นกรุงเทพฯก็ไปถึงอีสาน
แบบ 5:00 นอะไรอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนักเรียนอื
อ่าถึงเช้าคุณก็นอนบนรถไฟ
อือเพะรถไฟมีหลายราคาไงมีถูกๆก็จะนอนไม่
ได้นะคะนอนไม่โอเคนอนหลายๆคนเนี่ยรถไฟแบบ
เยไม่โอเคมั้ยไม่โอเคใช่ค่ะแต่อีสานเมีรถ
ไฟให้เลือกเยอะค่ะนักเรียนมีตั้งแต่แบบ
คือนักเรียนนั่งได้ตั้งแต่ 7 ชมงอ่ะค่ะจน
ถึง 10 ชมงอ่ะอืเอา 5 แล้วกันแล้วแต่ว่า
คุณนักเรียนไปจังหวัดไหนเนาะอืแต่ส่วน
ใหญ่เนี่ยคนไทยจะไปอีสานประมาณตรงนี้
ประมาณตรงนี้ขึ้นไปนะคะนี่ประมาณตรงนี้
อ่าประมาณตรงนี้เนาะก็ประมาณแบบอ่ะซัก 6
แล้วกัน 6 ชมงถึง 10 ชมถ้ารถไฟเร็วๆแพงๆ
แพงๆครูหญิงก็คิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ 1,200 นะ
1,200 แต่อนี้นอนสบายมี WiFi นะคะอันนี้
ดีใช่ใช่อแล้วนักเรียนก็ตื่นมาก็ฮัลโหล
อีสานเลยอือุ้ยก็ดีนะอันโอเคนะเพจะไป
เนี่ยค่ะ 1,200 อืใช่โอเคนะไม่แพงอันนี้
ไปอย่างเดียวหรือเปล่าผู้หญิงไม่แน่ใจนะ
คะแต่ว่ารถทัวร์รถทัวร์อีสานก็โอเคนะคะเา
มีแบบอ Economic  business  class  first
class นะมี CL ให้นั่งนะจริงหรอกี่
ชั่วโมงล่ะครูหญิงผู้หญิงคิดว่ารถทัวร์
อาจจะซัก
5-7 ช่วโมงนะอืก็คือแล้วแต่นักเรียนไป
อีสานที่ไหนอ่ะนะคะเ่าแต่ไม่รถทัวร์เร็ว
เร็วกว่ารถไฟแน่นอนอันนี้ว่าน่าจะประมาณ
นี้นะเพราะว่าอย่างกรุงเท่เอ่อถ้าแบบ
ชลบุรีใช่มั้ยชลบุรีที่นี่แล้วก็ไป
ขอนแก่นขอนแก่นอยู่ที่ไหน
อ่ะหาดูเจอมยิขอซูมก่อนนะคะอ่าเจอแล้วเจอ
แล้วนี่ขอนแก่นขอนแก่นอีสานใหญ่มากนะคะ
จากชลบุรีไปขอนแก่นเนี่ยขับรถก็ 5 ชมมอ่ะ
อืมกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยใกล้กว่าไงก็แล้วแต่นะคะ
คุณหญิงคิดว่าน่าจะ
ประมาณประมาณนั้นแหละอืๆรถัวก็ 5-7 ชมงนะ
คะอรถตู้อือาจจะไม่ขับก็ได้นะเพราะว่ามัน
ไกลมากมากนะคะรถตไม่แน่ใจนะถ้ามีก็รถ
ทัวร์ดีกว่านะคะนักเรียนครูหญิงยังบแล้ว
ก็ช้อยนึงที่อีสานเนี่ยไปได้ก็คือเครื่อง
บินโอ้เครื่องบินโอเคหรอแพงมโอก็แพงอ่ะนะ
ก็น่าจะ
แบบแต่ถ้ามีโปรโมชั่นก็ไม่รู้นะคะนัก
เรียนถ้าไม่มีโปรโมชั่นก็อาจจะ 1,000 บาท
ใช่มั้ยโ 1,000 บาทขึ้นไปนะคะเร็วใช่มั้ย
เร็ว 1 ช่วโมงมั้ยเออบางบางที่อาจจะ 45
นาทีก็มีนะครูฟ้าอืเร็วมาก 45 นาทีถึง
ประมาณแบบ 1 ชมครึ่งนะคะนี่เครื่องบินก็
เร็วใช่มั้ยเร็วนะคะนี่อีสานอ่ะต่อไปครู
ฟ้าอยากไปเที่ยวไหนอีก
อภาคเหนืออ้าภาคใต้ได้ค่ะภาคใต้นะคะนัก
เรียนช้อยส์ที่ดีที่สุดเครื่องบินทำไม
ูนักเรียนคะอันนี้กรุงเทพฯใช่มั้ยอ่าถ้า
เป็นกรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ไปอีสานเนี่ย
ถนนเนี่ยอถนนอาจจะเป็นแบบนี้ใช่มยแล้วก็
ตรงแล้วก็โค้งแล้วก็ตรงอันนี้คือถนนใช่ม
ถนนเวลาเราขับรถไปอีสานนะคะแต่ถ้าถนนไป
ภาคใต้อ่ะภาคใต้มีภูเขาภูเขาภูเขาภูเขา
เยอะฟ้าคิดดูว่าถนนมันอาจจะเป็นอย่างงนี้
นะคะ
อืคุยถนนขึ้นภูเขาลงภูเขาขึ้นภูเขาลงภู
เขาอืเครื่องบินก็เลยเป็นช้อยส์ที่ดีที่
สุดแต่ถ้านักเรียนขับรถเก่งขับรถไปภาคใต้
บ่อยๆเข้าใจถนนโอเคอแต่รู้สึกว่าช้อยส์
ที่ดีที่สุดสำหรับภาคใต้นะคะคนไทยถ้าจะไป
ภาคใต้คือนั่งเครื่องบินนะคิดว่าเลือก
ช้อยแรกเลยนั่งเครื่องบินเพราะว่ามันมี ow
คอสแบบถ้านกแอร์เนี่ยบางครั้งแบบ 600 ถึง
900 ก็มีนะแต่นกแอร์ยังมีอยู่หรือเปล่า
นะคะแบบทุกถูกอ่ะคุณโชคดีได้ราคาถูกๆนะคะ
ภาคใตู้้หญิงก็แนะนำเครื่องบินนะคะดีที่
สุดใช่ค่ะไอย์ที่ 2 ก็อาจจะเป็นรถไฟนะรถ
ไฟถฟเหรอใช่แต่รถไฟเนี่ยอืมนานนะคะนัก
เรียนน่าจะครูหญิงเช็คมาน่าจะประมาณ
14 ถึง 199 ชมงอ่ะ 14-19 ชมงอืมเพราะว่า
ภาคใต้ดูสิคะภาคใต้เนี่ยจากกรุงเทพฯลงมา
เนี่ยมันยาวขนาดไหนอ่ะครูฟ้าดู
ดิ
ไกลใช่ก็ 14-19 ชมมแต่ก็โอเคนะเหมือน
อีสานนะคะนอนได้มีหลายๆราคาก็กลางคืน
กรุงเทพฯใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ไปกลางวันไปเช้าอาจ
จะไม่เช้าอ่ะนะที่ภาคใต้นะคะรถไฟแล้วก็รถ
ทัวร์เอ่อรถทัวร์ก็โอเคนะอืแต่ต้องขับใช่
มยถนนที่มีภูเขาภูเขาภูเขาเยอะๆก็คนขับคน
ขับรถทัวร์เขาคก็เก่งแหละค่ะเก่งอือืๆๆ่
แต่รถทัวร์ก็อาจจะสัก 10 ชมงได้มย 10-14
มยคุณหญิงก็ไม่แน่ใจนะคะแต่เขาบอกว่าถ้า
เรานั่งรถทัวร์แล้วขับไปภาคใต้เนี่ยเรา
อาจจะรู้สึก
แบบเมาได้เพราะว่าถนนมันโค้งมากๆโอ้โหนาน
อยู่ดีนะคะรถโก็นานใช่ค่ะเครื่องบินก็เลย
ดีที่สุดนะคะนักเรียนอ่าสำหรับพรก็นัก
เรียนไปขึ้นที่หมอชิดนะ BTS หมอชิดแล้วก็
วินมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปนะคะเหมือนอีสานนะคะ
เหมือนกันอือ่ะครูฟ้าไปภาคอะไรต่อคะทัน
เหรอคะนะได้ค่ะอีก 1 ภาคกูฟ้าไปภาค
ภาคภาคเหนือเหรออ่ะภาคตะวันตกก็ได้นะภาค
เหนือเนี่ยภาคเหนือเหมือนภาคใต้นะคะรถไฟ
รถไฟแต่ว่ารถไฟจะประมาณ
10-14 ชมเนาะอแล้วก็เครื่องบินนะเครื่อง
บินก็เร็วเนาะ 1 ชมง 2 ชมงนะคะใช่แล้วก็
รถทัวร์ก็
9-1 ช่มมั้งประมาณนะคะรถทัวร์แต่ถ้าไป
ภาคตะวันตกใช่มยครูฟ้าอยากไปภาคตะวันตกอื
จะได้ครบทุกภาคนะคะภาคตะวันตกเนี่ยก็รถไฟ
โอเคนะประมาณ 4 ชมง 4
ชมงรถทัวร์โอเคก็น่าจะเหมือนชลบุรีเนาะ
2-3 ชมงนะคะรทโอเคแต่รถแต่รถทัวร์เนี่ย
ไปขึ้นหูไกลมากนะผู้หญิงไม่รู้อ่ะไม่รู้
มี BTS หรือเปล่า BTS สถานีอะไรไม่รู้นะ
คะใชค่ะไม่รู้ว่าไปเชียงใหม่ที่ยังไงใช่
ค่ะเอ่อไม่ใช่ไปเชียงใหม่สิไปกาญจนบุรีไป
กาจนบุรีใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะส่วนภาคกลางนะคะภาค
กลางเนี่ยรถไฟได้นะคะก็แล้วแต่นักเรียนไป
จังหวัดไหนเนาะก็ประมาณ 4  4 ถึง 8 แล้ว
กัน 8 ชมงนะคะแล้วก็รถทัวร์ใช่มยรถทัวร์
เนี่ยไปได้ทุกจังหวัดนะคะยกเว้นภาคใต้ไม่
โอเคภาคใต้เนี่ย Best  Choice  Good
Choice นะคะก็คือเครื่องบินเครื่องบินดี
สุดแต่ถ้าที่เหลือเนาะรถทัวร์อ่ะรถไฟโอเค
รถทัวร์โอเคคนไทยมากๆนั่งรถทัวร์กับรถไฟ
นะคะนักเรียนเนาก็ใช่ค่ะวันนี้เราพานัก
เรียนไปเที่ยวประเทศไทยนะคะส่วนวดีโอนี้
เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อน
นะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ